remember what Facebook CEO Mark
Zuckerberg told a Senate hearing back in
April there are certain content that
clearly we do not allow right hate
speech terrorist content nudity anything
that makes people feel unsafe in in the
community from that perspective that's
why we generally try to refer to what we
do as a platform like a platform for all
ideas really over the past few months
Facebook and other tech giants have
given us ample reason to doubt that
Proclamation the latest example started
early yesterday morning when Apple
pulled several podcasts associated with
a controversial and often incendiary
Alex Jones from the iTunes Store
Facebook followed suit on publishing
four of Jones pages claiming the videos
on those pages violated that hate speech
policy hours later YouTube decided it
wasn't going to miss out on all that
censorship fun and YouTube suspended the
Alex Jones channel with its 2.4 million
subscribers oh it's easy to dismiss
concerns about Big Tex actions all
coordinated it seems to shut down Jones
because of course he's the media's
poster child for conspiracy theories but
this isn't about Alex Jones this is
about freedom in our access to
information from the sources we as
individuals trust and like if big tech
can control the information flow then
they can also perhaps even influence the
outcome of the midterms and even future
presidential elections essentially our
shows have been deleted digitally D
platform from from these websites you
wonder if he'll have any influence going
forward because these private companies
have an incredible amount of control
over the Internet and that's the point
controlling who has a voice and who
doesn't on these monster platforms is
tantamount to limiting speech and as
you'll see in a moment it's also
viewpoint discrimination
back in February Facebook launched a new
rhythm that would cost top conservative
pages to see a dramatic drop in traffic
and this included personal pages by the
way president Trump's Facebook page saw
a 45 percent drop diamond and silk said
their content was similarly blocked on
Facebook
Facebook along with other social media
sites have taken aggressive actions to
silence conservative voices such as
ourselves by deliberately restricting
and weaponizing our page with algorithms
that censor and suppress our free speech
next it was YouTube who let conservative
influencers build up an audience for
years only to end up limiting their
channels temporarily de monetizing them
with no warning at all this has happened
to conservative commentators like ben
shapiro dave rubin and dennis prager
for many on the Left the view seems to
have become that if you can't beat them
prevent them from speaking just look at
what's happened on consider conservative
speakers on college campuses and after
liberal radio hosts flopped on Air
America remember them well some
Democrats sought to revive the Fairness
Doctrine to snuff out conservative talk
radio thankfully that went nowhere but
now they've moved on to the Internet in
squelching political speech there a
leaked proposal circulating among Senate
Democrats outlines a detailed plan to
take over the Internet by regulating
digital platforms and purging content
they deem harmful or inaccurate in other
words information they don't like it
would require social media users to be
tracked and labeled according to how
reasonable their content is deemed to be
Democrat Senator Chris Murphy even
hinted at this yesterday tweeting
Infowars is the tip of a giant iceberg
of hate and lies that uses sites like
Facebook and YouTube to tear our nation
apart these companies must do more than
take down one website the survival of
Arda
amok recei depends on it how dramatic
translation the survival of the
Democratic Party depends on it there's
no saying in TV and radio that content
is king same goes for the Internet if
they can shut down political speech on
the grounds that it's hateful you have
to ask where does this end if you want
to see hate check out some of the
comments on my Twitter feed after the
show tonight then you'll see hateful why
the leftist by the way always seem to
escape big text censors I know Louis
Farrakhan comes to mind he's a casual
racist of course and an anti-semite who
called white people quote potential
humans praised Hitler and blamed Jews
for 9/11 well he's still standing tall
on his Facebook page has a million
followers and what about those who
traffic and violence if Facebook really
cares about standards of safety I don't
think they'd be granting and Tifa
chapters from coast to coast where their
pages can plug their next thuggish
beatdown of conservatives with their
black hoods at all
and by the way if there's so much
concern of our conspiracy theories like
the one alex jones peddles well do
moments like this give social media
kings pause the fact of the matter is
he's not only bad because he's a liar
he's bad because he doesn't know how to
inspire people or evoke that emotion in
them of what about his rally knowing and
there first of all people are paid Chris
you know that people were paid since he
went down on the escalator
he pays people to show up at but I don't
Trump pays people to go to his rallies
that would be a lot of money she still
has a YouTube channel the truth is we
conservatives always want more political
speech not less of it even when it's
offensive to us our only point usually
about speech is limiting it if there's a
direct incitement to violence or
material that's injurious to children
but political speech in general we want
more now while Facebook and Apple are
private companies and thus are
state actors for First Amendment
purposes they better be really careful
with these moves to circumscribe certain
groups political speech because voters
in the future they might just demand
that Facebook Twitter YouTube be treated
more like public utilities public
utilities that have to operate in the
public interest for instance a utility
can't refuse to give electricity to a
family because they disagree with their
views or you know heaven forbid because
they're of a different race they act in
the public interest Ted Cruz by the way
in response to the Alex Jones purge said
tech tech companies have quote a degree
of power and an ability to censor that
William Randolph Hearst at the height of
yellow journalism could never have
imagined they have the bill the ability
if there is a speaker who is disfavored
simply to silence the speaker your words
float off into oblivion and nobody hears
them well he's right about their power
the big five tech companies are now
worth an estimated four trillion dollars
well that figure puts them above the GDP
of all but seven countries on the planet
the immense size of these companies is
concerning but so too is the speed in
which with which they can succumb to
external pressure point in case just
three weeks ago Mark Zuckerberg defended
keeping Infowars on his platform look at
that the things that are getting the
most distribution if people flag them as
potential hoaxes we send those to
fact-checkers and if those fact checkers
say that that it is provably false then
we will significantly reduce the
distribution right of that content why
don't you want to just say get off our
platform well look as abhorrent as some
of this content can be I do think that
it gets down to this principle of giving
people a voice all right so why did he
end up caving here well we'll continue
to demand answers for you
remember when disgraced FBI agent Peter
struck texted Lisa Paige about an
insurance policy to keep Trump from
getting elected remember that well maybe
just maybe these latest moves are the
beginning of Big Tex own version of an
insurance policy to see that someone
with Trump's views never reaches a
position of authority in government
again and that's the angle